I knew some guys in high school that
just totally crush they got all the
girls phone numbers with magic tricks I
think I tried that struck two video
games I was lonely in high school now
you see me too tonight you see me too is
the sequel to now you see me one
involves the four horsemen actually we
have a new horseman isla Fisher got
pregnant I guess it's what I hear
anyways the report I'm getting on you
know Google Google six months ago that
is so now we have Lizzy Caplan she's
stepping in and now numerically there
are still four horsemen but she's not
the same character different character
but now someone's out to destroy the
four horsemen so it just kind of takes
them around the world so who's gonna
scheme who who's gonna beat who the
Battle of the magician okay so now you
see me to has some pretty slick stuff
there are things that like in this movie
first of all Lizzy Caplan I actually
like her edition yes granted she kind of
straddles the line between is she
annoying or does she just have a lot of
positive energy personally I liked her
energy that she brought to the movies I
was glad to have her on board and the
movie as unbelievable as the magic in
this movie is I mean some of its
believable for sure you've seen it done
before you've seen variants and
derivatives of it done before so you buy
it other things you're like that's just
not possible I'm sorry there is a really
sweet scene involving pat downs and then
trying to hide something I was the
coolest scene in the movie and in the
movie that's ultimately taking the
character sector from the first one and
running with this so it's an evolution
of the character bill that we got in the
first one you love seeing that it's not
just a movie about magic and la-dee-da
and it's just old that's all it is it's
magic robin hood's that really is about
them does it always work no but it is
however with things you like there are
things you don't like first of all I'm
gonna get this right out of the way
right now Woody Harrelson's brother in
this movie useless
he's also played by Woody Harrelson I
really feel like Woody Harrelson was
like alright I'll sign on for the second
movie if I can play two roles well we've
lost isla Fisher we can't lose two so
all right I guess you gets to play two
roles I mean really what did this guy do
in the movie other than just be dumb as
well yeah he was magician smart but
I'm just saying for his relevance no
it's not there he didn't do anything
anything that he did they could have
just gone around I just the entire movie
I'm looking at this guy like why are you
here and if you're gonna have a
character has a character why haven't be
Woody Harrelson's brother played by
Woody Harrelson also it's just a weird
Escala man I feel like the
something else going on behind the
scenes that we just don't know about
yeah and like in the production of the
movie there's got to be a reason they
made that call and with woody harrelson
talent he hypnotizes people they're
actually like three people in this movie
that can hypnotize people in the way
they hypnotize they literally walk up to
them they're like you listen to my voice
all right I'm the only voice you trust
right sleep and they're asleep
and you're like yeah that's Anil
hypnotizing takes work man and you can't
hypnotize someone who doesn't want to be
hypnotized and yet suspending your
disbelief is necessary in some cinematic
experiences but in this case you just
can't suspend your disbelief that much
and the kind of plays into a lot of
things in this movie were a heist movie
with magicians in rival magicians it
would be really cool if the magic was
actually practical you would almost feel
like hey if I learned magic I could be a
superhero that's awesome or at least I
could you steal some but it's just
so unbelievable in this movie I thought
Daniel Radcliffe was fine in this movie
I thought he was really good it might be
because I thought he was good because
Woody Harrelson's brother was so useless
and that's just my point it's like
Daniel Radcliffe is doing fine why not
just have him in the movie why hath Lee
Harrelson stupid brother I'm gonna
about that the entire time but in the
end this movie overreaches it tries to
be so big because it has a case of
sequel itis with a little bigger is
better now bigger is not always better
in a movie about magicians and magic and
out tricking the other person less is
better subtlety is much better than what
they have in this movie in the end it
wraps up your luck I didn't buy most of
that but yeah that entertaining
part however underneath that polish
there wasn't really much there that you
really cared about and that whole magic
Illuminati thing I'm not buying it I
just I wonder why it's even in this I
guess we'll call it a saga now now you
see me tea would probably be much better
if you're drunk yeah and now it's a
party alright guys so now you see me -
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to say more
you